You've made a few reports and charts and put them
into a dashboard. Let's take a minute and discuss the kinds
of charts that you can use to visualize your data.
Let's take a minute to discuss the different types of charts
that are available to us. Bar or column charts are
good for comparing amounts. Line charts are good for showing changes
over time. Pie charts are good for showing a proportion
of a single value. Doughnut charts are like a pie chart,
but also displays the total amount itself. Funnel charts are often used
to represent stages in a sales process, and show the amount of potential
revenue for each stage. Scatter charts show the relationship between two sets of
data. See if you can choose the best chart for the following scenarios.